[Music]
we're now for the Tel Aviv protesters
after 30 weeks of this they failed to
stop Parliament passing legislation
which weakens the Supreme Court's
ability to check the power of the
executive we had a very successful
country very happy country Democratic
country and now we're going to lose all
of that what do you think is the risk
for this country that the religious
people will rule and we want a liberal
Israel these generally secular and
liberal Israelis still make up around
half the nine million population but
they find themselves with the most
right-wing government in Israel's
history Chuck freylick is a former
National Security advisor he says
Israelis have ignored a series of issues
that have bubbled up over decades and
that includes the occupation of the West
Bank it's one is this whole judicial
reform I call it a Judicial wrecking
ball it's the rise of the alto Orthodox
and it's also the Palestinian issue
which is reaching an inflection point
there are some who maintain that
separation is irreversible a two-state
solution is no longer viable and others
will say well we're near that point but
and I think what you see is liberal is
saying well wait a minute we're afraid
that we are near that point and we don't
want to reach it and that's why these
three different uh issues have converged
and created this eruption and Israel's
military says there's been an increase
in requests from reservists to abstain
from duty this it says will gradually
damage War Readiness if it carries on
even this has left the government
unmoved it is extraordinarily dangerous
and I think most people are
even people who support this as a sort
of Last Resort
are deeply deeply worried about the
ramifications because Israel does face
serious threats whether it's Iran
and how do we handle that and other
people saying well there is a higher
morality at the moment prime minister
Benjamin Netanyahu says these protesters
are trying to thwart his Democratic
mandate what he calls legal reforms will
he says balance government branches and
there'll be more battles in the months
ahead the Supreme Court has been
petitioned to strike down a law that
weakens its ability to strike down laws
there you have a potential
constitutional crisis these protesters
say they're here to stay
Bernard Smith Al Jazeera Tel Aviv